turkish soldiers being evacuated from
syria after being attacked by syrian
government forces images like these have
created shock and anger in Turkey and
growing calls for revenge Turkish
military hit Syrian army positions in
retaliation for the death of dozens of
its soldiers in southern Italy Turkey
blames the Syrian government for the
airstrike that targeted a military
outpost officials here also accuse
Russia failing to deter Syrian
government forces who have recently
stepped up their attacks against Turkish
soldiers this attack happened despite
the location of our troops being
coordinated in advance with Russian
officials on the ground
unfortunately the attack continued after
we have warned following the first
strike feeling abandoned by its EU
allies turkey warned it won't prevent
refugees from crossing into Europe
European countries are alarmed this
might turn into a mass exodus of
refugees fleeing the conflict in Syria
Turkey has been calling on the EU to
share the burden of the refugee crisis
and on NATO to deploy Patriot besides on
the border with Syria but NATO doesn't
seem to be willing to provide military
support offering for the time-being
words of sympathy I call on them to stop
their offensive to respect international
law and to back UN efforts for a
peaceful solution this dangerous
situation must be de-escalated and we
urge an immediate return to the 2018
cease-fire as tension mounts turkish and
russian officials held talks in Ankara
to defuse tension turkey wants the
Syrian army to pull out behind the
Demilitarized Zone stop its offensive
and allow civilians to return home
Russia is a key ally of President Bashar
al-assad who rejects turkeys expanded
presence in Syria and insists the
offensive by his troops in Italy is
legitimate and will continue and if
Russia and Turkey failed to overcome
their differences they might end up
bogged down in a wider and prolonged
regional confrontation in Syria hapara
al Jazeera Jill Vega Zoo on Turkey's
border with Syria